jerry well there's likely some cleanup
that needs to be done today from last
night's storm that hammered the valley
but we sure did need the rain mary jane
belliesa is live with a look at some of
the impacts she's at pitman wash on
arroyo grande near pebble road this
morning good morning mary jane
hi sherry good morning to you i mean
just take a look at the view with where
we're at as you mentioned we had a quick
storm last night but it definitely did
pack a punch you can already see most of
this trail that's located in pitman wash
is already pretty flooded you see pools
of water there even some debris we got
some plastic bottles that have washed up
over here and this is a really important
part of henderson because it does help
control some of those flood waters on
the other side but you can just tell how
much rain some areas got more so than
others in the valley and we've also got
really good viewer video that most of
you sent us just of how much rain you
got in and out of the area too so i want
to thank you for sharing your videos
with us we have one viewer video this
one's just really incredible uh this
comes in from viewer nathan he says this
happens every time it rains it's on farm
road and virginia dale street he says
he's notified the las vegas valley water
district several times to clean out the
storm drain and even had to notify first
responders because the cat bus hit that
manhole cover there and went flying down
the street just to show the impact that
the storm really brought in last night
it's usually hit or miss sometimes when
we have monsoonal storms just because
some are better than others as we know
it's really unpredictable here in the
las vegas valley especially growing up
here so you just got to be prepared
anytime you're outdoors and even being
out here when it comes into the trails
you can just see most of the people
walking out here are kind of walking
around where the water is at so just be
prepared as we get more of those storms
coming in for the weekend reporting live
in henderson mary jane ballissa live
local now pittman washes a nice place
for a morning stroll mary jane thank you
very much